there's actually a better way to do this
remember i said to you this is um
this is method one and it's kind of
arbitrary you know it's
why are we doing in this particular way
i want to show you a better way
with a funkier name okay it's got two
names actually okay
so make a new subheading we're gonna do
the same question but we're gonna
go through it in a different order
okay so if you really want a sound
really um
technical then gaussian elimination
that's what you want to call this which
is named after
gauss okay um well done
why is it called elimination you'll see
why in a second let's have a look
through the working
okay i'll explain the other name in a
second
have a look at this um this row what
have we done to it
what have we done to it or i should say
look at this system what have we done to
the rows
the first thing you notice is i haven't
just changed one row have i
what else have i changed which rows have
i adjusted
two and three what have i done to them
are you
subtracted good yeah i
subtracted the top row from both
of the other rows so
like so go back there we go okay
whoops that should say let's fix that
okay there we go
yeah sure see them again thank you okay
okay where were we that's fine now
you think about why this is the process
what am i trying to eliminate
hmm look carefully i
i'm trying to eliminate constants but
not just any constants i'm trying to
eliminate the first one
okay i'm getting to a particular form as
you'll see
okay all right have a look at the next
row the next system i should say
how have i changed it what have i done
second row is the same i've just changed
the third row i've just multiplied
okay so watch here we go
all right why do you think i did that
you already have seen why we might
multiply or divide by certain things
what am i aiming at yeah i'm trying to
eliminate down here see that
see that zero how did i get that zero
there
i added two rows which careful of the
order which rows did i add
two three three plus two good you can
see
obviously that's why that's the ten
right because it's the six plus the four
so you can see what's going on
right okay now i want you to um put a
big
sort of colorful mark around this
particular line because this is
important
i'll write it down and i'll show you why
okay this is important because have a
look at remember i said this is actually
this is an augmented
augmented matrix so it's two matrices
together okay
i want you to look at the left hand
matrix
okay this is special right this
arrangement
is important because see where the zeros
are right
what they've formed is all of my
coefficients that count
they form this kind of shape it's kind
of triangular it's called an echelon
so this form is called row echelon
form okay now you're like
so what you know what's the big deal
okay there's a triangle there you know
thumbs up to you well as you'll see in a
second once you have
any matrix any matrix in this form
everything is really easy to solve it
just kind of falls out by itself
actually okay so gaussian elimination
the goal
is to get to this form and then you just
have to do really simple things to solve
it
okay so we've gotten here now have a
look at how quickly the solution falls
out
right what have i done here again look
carefully
i've played with more than one row
i divided the last row right i divided
by negative five because obviously i
just want this
to turn into a one right so i did that
after i turned it into a one what did i
follow that with
subtract
row two take away
row three right because that'll exactly
get rid of
this one here you see that all right let
me let me unfold it
okay so i did the division first and
then i subtract it
okay then i just had to divide
you can see there row two has been
divided so i get
the one in the middle okay and now i'm
in the same position as before more or
less
and i do the same thing i take away
those two rows
okay now a couple of things why is this
better
why is this better it's not just shorter
by the way why is it better
ah thank you right see see this
echelon form right you're just nearly
this is two days in a row right
i expect you to have some really bad
days after this that's okay once you're
in row echelon form
once you have these zeros over here in
some ways you don't need to worry about
what to do
next all you have to do is eliminate
what's
over here on the right hand side right
and then when you finish
what you get is this thing
right so when you look at the numbers
right you can just read off
a b c because that's what each one tells
you
it's in order okay so row echelon form
directly goes
to this okay just like this is nice
anita has a special name
this also is really nice and neat and
also has a special name
it's called the identity matrix
okay more specifically this one here is
the three
by three identity matrix you can have
identity matrices that are bigger
or smaller for instance what do you
think the two by two identity metrics
would look like
one zero one zero zero one zero one
and you could make it bigger if you
liked um
you get the idea now part of the
question for you is
why is it called the identity matrix